Everyone is panicking about
new salary requirement for skilled work visa
because it just said to become 38,700 per year
after spring 2024.
It is quite high.
But what if I told you
that if you are intention student in the UK,
you shouldn't worry as much
and it actually might be beneficial for you.
What? At the moment
the minimum salary requirement is £26,200,
which is quite reasonable for skilled worker visa.
What you might not know
is that actually
if you want national student
and you're switching from your student visa
to a skid worker visa
or switching from a graduate visa,
you don't have to meet this salary requirement.
You only have to meet the salary requirement
of 20,960 per year.
Why is that?
Because you're considered new entrant to the market.
There is no information
and that they will remove new entrant route.
Which means
that different students will only have to meet
70% of the required salary of 38,700.
And it will mean that their minimal requirement
for their students will be £27,000.
Around that,
uh, in salary.
Unfortunately,
it's just a prediction.
We don't know if the new entrance rule will remain
and what will be the minimum salary requirement.
This might be a bit controversial,
but I think that
because it will be very difficult to bring news
people on skilled worker visa
because IT companies will have to pay them more,
they will prefer to hindrato students
with a much lower salary
Requirement.
I'll keep you posted with the most recent updates.